saw war ein wirklich bemerkenswerter
sturm eigentlich nicht besonders groß
waren seine folgen doch immens der
bahnverkehr in norddeutschland wurde
komplett eingestellt
mindestens sieben toten bis zu 61 liter
regen pro quadratmeter
windgeschwindigkeiten von 180 kilometern
pro stunde
und so weiter und so fort das bild hier
das habe ich gestern auf instagram
gepostet das ist schon absolut irre so
war auch kein normaler sturm sondern ein
schnellläufer was das ist und warum die
ausführung so dramatisch sind und was
das ganze mit dem klimawandel zu tun hat
jetzt den krieg zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
wow was für ein bild so sah es gestern
auf dem kudamm in berlin aus nichts ging
mehr in der bundeshauptstadt auf dem
kurfürstendamm vor kein bus mehr der s
bahn betrieb war komplett eingestellt
worden
und bundesweit war es absolut verheerend
kein zug fuhr mehr in bremen hamburg
schleswig-holstein niedersachsen
brandenburg mecklenburg-vorpommern und
natürlich auch in berlin
im gesamten norden der republik und das
ist auch am tag danach noch immer
dramatisch da laufen im moment noch die
reparaturen auf vielen strecken geht
eben immer noch nichts fährverbindungen
wurden eingestellt stromausfälle und es
gab sieben tote meistens übrigens durch
umstürzende bäume also besser drinnen
bleiben bei solch heftigen stürmen aber
was war an so ungewöhnlich warum hat ein
so kleiner sturm so krasse auswirkungen
die antwort ist ganz einfach aber
erklärungsbedürftig ist ein
schnellläufer nach seiner entstehung in
der nacht zum mittwoch im südwesten
island zucker mit einem tatsächlichen
affenzahn nach deutschland möglich macht
das der jetstream rund um die arktis in
einer höhe von rund zehn kilometern
zieht er mit rund 200 bis 500 kilometern
pro stunde rund um die arktis und
beeinflusst unser wetter maßgeblich er
schiebt hoch und tiefdruckgebiete hin
und her
und je nachdem wie ihr verläuft kann er
auch mal ein tiefdruckgebiet mit hoher
geschwindigkeit in den süden kicken ja
das muss man schon sagen in diesem fall
das übrigens auch eine folge des
klimawandels der jackson der wart immer
mehr nach süden eine folge der immer
wärmeren arktis die den polaren
jetstream schwächt der fängt dadurch an
im wahrsten sinne des wortes herum zu
eiern
es bilden sich beulen im stream die
sogenannten roski wellen sie bringen
paradoxerweise jetzt auch kalte
polarluft mit viel schnee weiter in den
süden der blizzard in den usa im märz
der war dafür ein perfektes beispiel ein
wintersturm im märz auf den breitengrad
von süditalien absolut verrückt eine
roski welle hatte ihn verursacht genauso
wie jetzt klar wie und dadurch das sei
relativ klein war ging es auch besonders
schnell die welt meteorologie
organisation kurz wm hat alarm
geschlagen zitat wir
bemerkenswerte veränderungen rund um den
planeten welche an die grenzen von
unserem verständnis des klimawandels
geht wir sind jetzt auf wirklich
unerforschtes gebiet ja das sagt david
carr cs direktor des weltklima
forschungsprogramms der wm ja also
selbst experten wissen jetzt nicht mehr
weiter
nur eins ist sicher nichts ist sicher
niemand kann mir sagen wie viele und wie
heftig stürme in zukunft sein werden das
bestätigte heute auch der klimaforscher
am helmholtz-zentrum für ozeanforschung
in kiel mojib latif ist gebe zitat keine
anhaltspunkte dafür dass sind folge des
klimawandels solche extreme weiter
zunehmen werden ja das sagte er am
freitag im südwestrundfunk achtung die
betonung liegt auf solche denn sie
werden natürlich diese stürme durch die
ausreißer der ostbevern er mal zu uns in
den süden getrieben was dann doch für
uns eher mehr als weniger stimme
bedeutet und durch den temperaturanstieg
in deutschland der laut latif seit 1881
bei 1,4 grad liegt da kann die luft dank
mehr wasser aufnehmen es regnet dadurch
stärker bei solchen wetterlagen zudem
hält er mehr extremwetter grundsätzlich
für wahrscheinlich zitat wir erwarten
dass in zukunft wetter extreme häufiger
werden
zitat ende es wird also ziemlich
spannend was das wetter betrifft hier
bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden wenn er kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann durch mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke hier also hier geht es weiter
mit klimawandel weltweites wetterchaos
hat begonnen
ja da gibt es noch mehr hintergrundinfos
zum thema sehr spannendes thema übrigens
also auf keinen fall verpassen und drauf
legen und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran